good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight John fetterman is a
trust fund kid he took money from his
parents deep into middle age when he
decided finally what he would like to do
with the rest of his life which is to be
the U.S senator from Pennsylvania the
problem is fate intervened and he can
now no longer speak he had a bad stroke
and we feel bad about that everyone does
but because of that stroke fetterman now
needs electronic assistance in order to
communicate with other people
can't talk on his own it's not a
right-wing conspiracy theory he's not
queuing on it's real in fact it's so
real his campaign concedes that it's
real that it's true fetterman uses a
software program to understand the words
of those around him and to formulate his
responses to those words in other words
to talk
now to be perfectly clear this software
is not a hearing aid fetterman doesn't
need a hearing aid because he isn't deaf
he's not hearing impaired instead this
program takes words and then rearranges
them into language that John fetterman
can understand because his brain can no
longer do that for him
that's sad for transhumanists though it
is thrilling this is an amazing moment
this is Neil Armstrong on the Moon here
you have the one of the most famous
politicians in the country merging with
a computer this is the future they
imagine they're thrilled by it
but for everyone else for the voters of
Pennsylvania for example it does raise
some obvious questions for example where
exactly does the software end in John
fetterman's Consciousness begin
we don't know we can't know
but it's obvious that Pennsylvania could
very well be sending a computer program
to the U.S Senate where inevitably it
will be hacked
yesterday MSNBC sat down with John
fetterman and his thinking machine to
assess where the man ends and the
Machine begins and the initial
Impressions we're not at all encouraging
we had a monitor set up so that he could
read my questions because he still has
lingering auditory processing issues as
a result of the stroke which means he
has a hard time understanding what he's
hearing now once he reads the question
he's able to understand you'll hear he
also still has some problems some
challenges with speech and I'll say
Katie that just in some of the small
talk prior to the interview before the
closed captioning was up and running it
did seem that he had a hard time
understanding our our conversations
well good for admitting that that's a
rival Channel don't watch a lot of MSNBC
but she should tell viewers that and she
did and what she just told you is that
before the machine was turned on John
fetterman could not understand human
language not even small talk but once
the machine was plugged in he sounded or
the machine sounded nearly human
but don't worry everything's going to be
fine in the Senate as long as there's
not a power outage it's not like the
electricity ever goes down in this
country we definitely have enough
Renewables to keep John fetterman voting
the right way for the next six years
better build some more wind farms that's
the plan
but once again to the credit of the
MSNBC reporter she did ask a follow-up
how do we know your thinking machine
isn't going to break John Federman can
we see a doctor's report on this
here's how that exchange went
can voters stress that you will be able
to do this job on day one
yeah of course so you say you're on the
road to full recovery but right now
voters really have to take your word for
it we've asked for your medical records
we've asked to have a conversation with
someone from your medical team to
interview your physician you've declined
those requests why
well I I feel like we have been very
transparent in a lot of different ways
when our doctor has already given a
letter saying that I'm able to serve and
to to be uh running I mean respectfully
that letter from your physician that was
six months ago don't voters deserve to
know your status now
being on in front of thousands and
thousands of people and having
interviews and getting around all across
Pennsylvania that gives everybody and
the voters decide you know if they think
that it's it's really the issue
so he's reading that off a screen and by
the way we're taking him in his word
that there's not a staffer backstage
typing out the answers because he
himself can't formulate them now again
you can feel deeply sympathetic to John
fetterman that's sad to watch but this
is a guy who wants to run the federal
government in a body of a hundred
the most powerful legislative body in
the world and he wants to be a member of
it so over at CBS reporter Ed O'Keefe
asked the obvious question quote will
pennsylvanians be comfortable someone
representing them who had to conduct a
TV interview this way
now that's a mild way to put it but it's
certainly a fair observation
the guy's reading his answers off a
screen with the reporter three feet away
that's the definition of impairment and
again this is a very serious job
but others in the media scoffed at the
idea that was a problem at all in fact
far from being a problem it was an asset
because if the equity agenda means
anything it means that incompetent
people ought to be in charge that's
equity
as New York city councilwoman Rita
Joseph put it questions about
fetterman's profound brain damage are
quote incredibly ableist
ableist we desperately need more
diversity in elected office and that
includes people with speech impediments
well we desperately need that that is
absolutely right
but actually we're not talking about a
speech impediment she's telling us he's
got a stutter just like Joe Biden
remember when they told you that Joe
Biden's dementia was just a stutter
impediment would not prevent fetterman
or Biden from understanding other
people's speech
huh investigative reporter Hunter Walker
the Retro Rolling Stone in the New
Yorker answered that question with a
question of Zone quote would they treat
a deaf person like this for needing
assistance
oh so a few questions about John
fetterman you hate the deaf
you're a hearingist bigot we're gonna
close down your bank account at JP
Morgan ableist
but again it's not really relevant to
the senate race in Pennsylvania because
once again John Federman doesn't have
hearing problems he's not deaf this is
in deafness this is brain damage
so the independence Eric Michael Garcia
tried to tie up that loose end and he
used an analogy to do it that's how
really smart people talk how is this any
different he wrote from Tammy Duckworth
or Madison cawthorne needing a
wheelchair
oh so John fetterman being unable to
talk without reading it off a screen
either from the software from one of his
staffers backstage is exactly the same
as being wounded in defense of your own
country it's a war injury
and then John fetterman's wife
who came into this country as an illegal
alien by the way wondered the same thing
and we're quoting truly appalling have
these journalists never heard of The
Americans with Disabilities Act really
curious to learn how they feel about
Wheelchairs and glasses
end quote really so your questions about
John fetterman's mental health the
Acuity of his brain his ability to talk
and listen and reason uses higher
faculties those questions are banned by
the Americans Disabilities Act because
he's not just an incompetent guy trying
to take over the country no he's
disabled
over at Vox Ian millheiser says he knows
exactly how fetterman's bigoted critics
view people with eyeglasses Dr Kevin
Rouge quote is it the position of NBC
news that a senator with glasses cannot
be trusted in office because they use
assistive technology to accommodate
their disability
it's so unbelievable not only can you
not ask questions about the guy you're
supposed to vote for and whether he can
actually represent you in the United
States Senate you're not allowed
he's fine and by the way the fact he's
not fine is the reason to vote for him
so they're hitting you from both sides
vote for him because he's so profoundly
disabled we don't have enough of those
in the Senate but if you note these
profoundly disabled you're a bigot
whoa they got you coming and going have
you heard this before does it sound kind
of familiar where they take someone with
an obvious impairment and then they use
him
to accrue more power for themselves it's
not really about the disabled person
it's about them
and then if you ask questions about it
shut up
does the term Greta thundberg come to
mind that's the girl it's always
lecturing you about global warming and
how you're evil
got a thundberg is someone who needed
help and concern from adult adults at
the age of 11 she lost 22 pounds because
according to her parents she was so
depressed about global warming that she
couldn't eat
and then she was diagnosed with a whole
Suite of very serious problems OCD
mutism Asperger's very very sad actually
but the people around Greta thundberg
and the people who used Greta thundberg
didn't see this as sad at all they saw
it as an advantage for them because
Greta thundberg could be used to accrue
more power to them and you weren't
allowed to say anything about it because
she was disabled which by the way you
weren't allowed to notice here's Greta
thundberg
you all come to us young people for hope
how dare you
you have stolen my dreams in my
childhood with your empty words we are
in the beginning of a mass extinction
and all you can talk about is the money
and fairy tales of Eternal economic
growth how dare you
so you look at that and on one level you
think
why is this person lecturing me someone
who's never had a job before is in
charge of like our energy policy that's
crazy and then the other level the more
deep level the more important level you
realize what a tragedy you just saw here
is someone who is profoundly troubled
who needs real help and care and empathy
and love from the adults in her life but
she's not getting any of that instead
she's being carted out like a sideshow
freak for the prophet of others they're
using that child in exactly the way
they're using Joe Biden
and John fetterman and by the way Kamala
Harris the dimmest person ever to work
in American politics none of them have
any idea what's going on and they're
being used by people for the benefit of
those people
but you can't say anything
because you would be against people with
disabilities in the Ada prohibits you
from doing that
right you're supposed to accommodate
Greta thundberg's disability pretend her
words were profound just like the fake
poet at Biden's inauguration oh she was
so great we dare you to say she wasn't
she was ridiculous but you did not make
oh yeah so profound
and Greta thundberg's case of course the
media loved it because they could use
her too they could use granothermic they
didn't care anything about she could die
and they wouldn't care they'd find
someone else to use as a marionette for
their own political Ambitions watch them
perhaps the most impressive and
impassioned remarks have come not from a
president or a prime minister but 16
year old climate activist Greta
tuneberry she is the teenager on strike
for the planet our house is on fire
times person of the year change is
coming whether you like it or not Greta
tunberg is leading a generation of
climate kids Greta first of all I gotta
reassess My Life Choices Chris that is a
force to be reckoned with Greta tunberg
the Swedish girl who inspired so much he
said she was in a deep depression when
she understood the warnings of science
but turned that depression into action
and you see the result here today
Greta's passion does reflect what really
is happening and we're still arguing
whether or not it exists
she turned that depression into action
well no she didn't actually she's living
in hell like most emotionally unbalanced
children She's suffering but she don't
care because you can use her you did
nothing to support her to love her to
cure her serious mental illness
no you used her to take more power
and if anyone says anything about it
if you think children shouldn't go on
television
to talk about climate policy and energy
then you're a bigot you hate children
you hate Greta tunberg
and by the way as you sit and watch the
results of the lunatic policy that she's
espousing without even understanding
Europe's energy grid collapsing
then you're a bad person as Vox reported
a tax on Greta tunberg exposed the
stigma autistic girl's face no they
expose the callousness and cynicism of
her parents in MSNBC anchors and
everybody else who used her suffering to
their own benefit
The Washington Post complaint autistic
young people deserve serious respect and
attention not dismissal as the Pawns of
others really
whose Pawn is Greta thunberg yours
researchers at the University of Albany
even published a study and tell a quote
analysis of ageism sexism and ableism
and user comments and YouTube videos
about climate activist Greta tunberg
oh so again
you need to listen to her because she's
not well but if you note that she's not
well you're a bigot
it's the same exactly the same Dynamic
you're watching with the president of
the United States Joe Biden who is not
well and everybody knows it Joe Biden
mourned the death of congresswoman
Jackie what else wolarski publicly then
a few weeks later he asked totally
befuddled why isn't she here at the
event
but if you notice that that happened
you're the ageist
you know my gosh come on you can't go
after him for you know not giving Aid to
Florida or not tackling the
infrastructure he's giving Aid to you
crazy so you can't go after him for that
but you can go after him for forgetting
that someone has passed I mean and she
passed last month not like a hundred
years ago I think what it really shows
is that this country is so ageist this
country has a problem with age and I
think they need to stop weaponizing his
age I hate right about this country
is a problem with age
so if you don't like the fact the
commander-in-chief the guy who commands
her nuclear Arsenal is deranged because
of age which he is
then you're the bigot but underneath all
of this
is this single most cynical political
move in the history of this country
and that is elevating Joe Biden
precisely because he is
fading away
because he is demented that's why they
chose him they had an option actually
his name was Bernie Sanders we're hardly
endorsing Bernie Sanders's program but
Bernie Sanders could think clearly and
the people around the Democratic party
just hated what he had to say so they
picked a guy who had nothing going on
upstairs who was flatlining mentally so
they could control him
that's exactly what they're doing with
fetterman subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight